well at today's press conference in
washington u.s president biden also said
that there is and i'm quoting here no
evidence that the city of mario poll has
fallen to russia now it comes after
moscow tried to claim victory there
saying russian forces have successfully
liberated the port city in ukraine some
two thousand soldiers and about one
thousand civilians are still believed to
be holding out inside the vast absence
of steel plant inside the city kiev is
demanding that moscow opened a
humanitarian corridor to let civilians
leave safely
president putin called off plans today
to storm that complex instead in a
televised meeting he told his defense
minister to completely seal off the area
our report now on the steel plant that
has become a symbol of ukrainian
resistance
the vast azov style steel plant
seen here in footage from russian state
television it's the last part of
mariupol under ukrainian control after
nearly two months of heavy fighting with
much of the strategic port in ruins
president putin has claimed victory in
the city and told his defence minister
to seal off its defenders in their last
stronghold
i consider the proposed storming of the
industrial area pointless i order to
abort it
there is no need to climb into these
catacombs and crawl underground through
these industrial facilities
block off this industrial area
so that not even a fly can get through
we'll never succeed in dominating but in
washington u.s president joe biden
dismissed putin's claims it's
questionable whether he does control
mario paul one thing for sure we know
about mario paul
he should allow humanitarian carters to
let people on that steel mill and other
places are buried under rubble to get
out to get out
that's what any any
any head of state would do in such a
circumstance and so
there is no evidence yet that mary paul
is completely full
ukrainian authorities have also urged
moscow to open humanitarian corridors to
allow those sheltering in the heavily
bombarded as of style plant to flee
these pictures provided by the plant's
defenders show some of the hundreds of
civilians said to be sheltering in
bunkers below the steel works
but previous efforts to organize
evacuations for mariupol have had little
success
some
thousand residents are thought to still
be living among the ruins
in kiev ukrainian president volody
mirzalenski speaking alongside his
spanish and danish counterparts remains
defiant in the face of russia's assault
announced that they will
bring more weapons to you yeah
i know that they've captured
most of mario paul a long time ago
we're very aware of that
but there is a part of our city where
our servicemen remain
and they'll stay there for now
with no surrender planned by those
blockaded in the azov style steel plant
there is growing concern that those
trapped inside could starve
all right let's bring the ndw's mathias
berliger he is in key force good evening
to you montias what do we know tonight
about the fate of those ukrainian
soldiers and civilians who are still
inside that steel plant in mario poll
not a lot i'm afraid but we know that an
estimated 2 000 servicemen and maybe 1
000 civilians maybe more maybe less are
still on that territory and that the
attack that has been uh going on for the
past few days has been aborted and that
putin has as we have seen ordered to
seal it off which means that he is
probably trying to starve these people
because of course their supplies are
limited their supply of ammunition is
limited and um the mayor has said today
that there is little hope for a corridor
to evacuate at least the civilians or
all of these people um because no
ceasefire could be achieved and all
there have been attempts of course to do
that and but they have failed so far
because um shelling had continued uh
during that time there will certainly be
i guess attempts to um to to establish
another corridor or to maybe exchange
those people trapped there for prisoners
there are all these things are being
discussed but for the moment um of
course the russians have the upper hand
they can just starve them
or just keep them in there as long as
they want in my teams we are also
getting reports tonight of mass graves
that have been found near mario pole
what more do we know about that
yeah this is satellite imagery has shown
that there were many uh fresh um
ditches
that look like graves in a place where
authorities have said that um russian
authorities have buried the dead we know
that or the the mayor of mario paul
estimates that 20 000 people
at least have died in these weeks where
the sun where the city was under siege
um that would be a big portion
a big part of of the people who had
still been
who had still been living there at the
beginning of the war and of course these
people need to be buried somewhere no
city has enough morgues for twenty 000
people
and with no electricity um what happened
in also in other places in ukraine was
that
the authorities either the occupiers or
even the civilians they would quickly
bury the people at least temporarily and
these big graves of course they said
these these images they support uh what
the mayor has said that the number of
people who died in this city is really
high and in kiev today the the spanish
and the danish prime ministers
came for a visit what more do we know
about what they said
well they have announced additional
weaponry aid they have a additional
military aid and
that um and and the spanish
prime minister has also visited one of
the places that was most devastated uh
by the russian that was occupied by
russia and he was deeply moved by what
he saw there it's of course a show of
solidarity and we see people we see now
heads of state or government arriving
here more frequently to show support for
ukraine
martinez berlin with the latest tonight
from kiev matthias as always thank you
all right we want to get a closer look
now at how things have changed on the
ground in ukraine this week dw's joel
delroy fills us in
this week ukraine's president declared
that the battle for the donbass had
begun russia also acknowledged that a
new phase in its operations was now
focusing on the important industrial
region to the east now since 2014
russian-backed separatists have
controlled parts of the donbass namely
the regions of donetsk and luhansk while
russia has also occupied crimea
now russian forces control an arc of
territory connecting the breakaway
regions to crimea and cutting ukraine
off from the sea of azov
in the latest developments this week
russia intensified its efforts to take
more territory across the donbass
it launched a battery of thousands of
air and artillery attacks on many points
along the front line now us analysts say
they believe that russia appears to be
trying to encircle ukrainian forces in
this pocket here between its territories
by one estimate up to 40 000 ukrainians
may be positioned there and that's about
20
of the known forces now these ukrainian
units are
expected to put up quite a fight because
they have been well practiced in
fighting separatists here for years
russia on the other side is estimated to
have up to 70 000 troops across the
south east including units which
retreated after failing to take the
capital kyiv
but some western analysts believe that
russian forces are not ready for this
new offensive they say they appear to be
rushing to attack without proper
training preparation or supply lines and
this week's bombings are being seen as a
test by russia to find weaknesses in the
front line before attempting to move any
tanks or troops forward ukraine
continues to call for more weapons from
western countries to try and hold the
russians back